[Musique]
François Baayou qui est notre invité
aujourd'hui président du MoDem maire de
pot d'être sur le plateau de dimanche en
politique merci d'être ici avant votre
rentrée officielle la semaine prochaine
puisque c'est la semaine prochaine he
les universités du MoDem peut-on
imaginer une élection présidentielle
sans vous on peut se poser la question
pour l'instant en tout cas vous soutenez
Alain Jupé mais rien ne dit que c'est
lui qui gagnera la primaire dans ce cas
vous aurez un boulevard devant vous on y
reviendra un peu plus tard les sondage
de popularité vous classe en tout cas
parmi les personnalités politiques
préférées des Français peut-être que
vous voudriez en faire quelque chose
aussi vous nous direz ça tout à l'heure
avant d'aller dans dans le vif du sujet
je voudrais qu'on parle de Jacques
Chirac on a appris dans la matinée qu'il
avait été hospitalisé pour infection
pulmonaire vous avez été son ministre
vous avez été son concurrent aussi à la
présidentielle euh vous avez eu des
nouvelles de sa santé récemment j'ai eu
des nouvelles comme tout le monde par
ceux qui l'ont rencontré et qui ont en
effet exprimé de l'inquiétude sur son
état je trouve que c'est un moment très
émouvant que que cet homme qui a connu
les plus hautes responsabilités soit
dans le dénuement comme ça de la maladie
et de la vieillesse et puis je pense au
siens je pense à sa fille Claude que euh
je pense à leur inquiétude et donc c'est
un c'est un signe qu'il faut que nous
leur transmettions c'est fait parmi les
thèmes qui vont s'imposer dans la
campagne présidentielle il va bien sûr y
avoir l'emploi l'inversion de la courbe
du chômage souhaité par François
Hollande ne s'est pas réalisé le
prochain président héritera du dossier
vous allez me dire ce sera pas le
premier hein parce que le chômage ça
fait quand même quelques années les
Français et l'emploi on a demandé aux
Français ce qu'ils en pensé dans la rus
et lors de la manifestation contre la
loi comerie jeudi à
Paris quand on me dit travail
rémunération récompense faire beaucoup
d'activités obligatoire c'est ce qui me
permet de payer mes factures à la fin du
mois de partir en vacances le travail
j'aime pas du tout il faudrait aboger il
y a la notion de des droits en fait des
garanties et ces garanties là
actuellement elles sont attaquées ça
peut être aussi une source de beaucoup
de stress de malêtre aussi ma vie de
travail elle est derrière mais je
continue à travailler socialement
bénévolement pour moi trouver du travail
avec la
motivation pour moi il y a pas de
problème tous les 6 mois par tranche de
2 mois il y a des petites périodes de
chômage comme tout le monde j'ai de la
famille des amis qui en on connu donc on
sait que derrière c'est moralement très
compliqué l'emploi me permet juste de
voir les les enseignent les boîtes qu'
cherchent mais passer par premploi en
soit ça marche pas des offres aussi de
plus en plus sur le bon coin pourquoi
pas même si la croissance est pas on est
autour de zéro il y a pas de raison
qu'il y a de moins en moins de travail
comment demain on va répartir le travail
il faut y réfléchir et partager
davantage le travail ça veut pas dire
non plus la modération salariale c'est
pas pour qu'après tout le monde se
retrouve pauvre en difficulté on réforme
à chaque fois notamment le code du
travail ser rien du tout après c'est
vrai qu'il y a des opportunités
étrangers qui sont parfois plus
intéressantes mais je je crois en la
France et je pense qu'il y a encore du
travail ici non faut pas quter la France
il faut faire une autre politique
François Baou il faut faire une autre
politique de l'emploi mais en attendant
vous avez entendu les gens qui vont
plutôt sur le bon coin pour trouver du
travail plutôt que sur Pôle emploi qui a
été réformé par Nicolas Sarkozi ça a été
un échec Pôle Emploi ça signe l'échec de
Pôle Emploi bon c'est un travail
extrêmement
difficile mais c'est vrai que on peut
pas
s'empêcher
de
comparer la situation française à la
situation de pays qui nous entourent et
qui sont au plein emploi et de ce point
de vue là il y a évidemment des
changements très importants à
apporter avec deux réserves que je veux
exprimé d'entrée la première c'est
que les contrats de travail qui sont
signés sont signés je pense que une
partie des difficultés que le
gouvernement a rencontré avec la
question du contat de travail c'est
qu'il il a voulu remettre en cause les
contrats de travail déjà signés ou que
les
franç penser cela la loi précédente et
celle-là les deux les deux lois donc ça
c'est le premier point et le deuxième
point raison pour laquelle j'ai exprimé
des de grandes réserves sur la loi c'est
que on ne doit pas baisser la
rémunération du travail le le problème
en France c'est évidemment un que les
emplois ne sont pas créés en nombre
suffisant il y a une deuxième question
c'est que le travail est mal payé et de
ce point de vue-là le signal qui a été
apporté par la loi de baisser la
rémunération des heures
supplémentaires ou de baisser la pour la
loi précédente la rémunération du
travail du dimanche sont de mauvais
signaux on pouvait tout à fait poser la
question du coût du travail ce que ça
coûte à l'entrepriseut sans remettre en
cause ce que ça rapporte au salariés
vous voyez qu'il y a un jeu sur les
charges sur ce genre d'HE la comery si
vous étiez élu à l'Élysée vous la
supprimeriez on peut pas dire les choses
comme ça parce qu'il y a tant de
dispositions un seul article fait
plusieurs dizaines de P est-ce que vous
la supprimeriez ou je je regarderais euh
décision par décision mesure par mesure
pour savoir ce qu'on doit remettre en
cause et je vous le dis pour moi en tout
cas quel que soi mes responsabilités je
demanderait qu'on remette en cause la
rémunération des heures supplémentaires
il y a aucune raison quand les gens
travaille davantage pour que on Vienne
couper les revenus qui sont en droit
d'attendre du travail et c'est une
réflexion générale sur la question de
des fins de mois qu'est-ce que ça
rapporte aujourd'hui la campagne se
focalise autour des questions d'identité
de oui mais aussi des 35 heur François
Baou et la question du revenu du travail
de ce que ça rapporte à la fin du mois
et pour moi une question de de la vie de
tous les jours centrale mais il y a
aussi les 35 heur tous les candidats de
la primaire à droite disent il faut
abolir les 35 heur est-ce que c'est une
position que vous défendezv euh je ne la
défendrai pas sous cette forme je pense
qu'il est légitime qu'on envisage de
travailler plus à condition que les
heures travaillé en plus soient payé en
heures supplémentaires à 25 % et pas à
10 % comme le seuil si on dit on
supprime les 35 heures on supprime le
seuil de déclenchement des heures su
donc il faut garder les 35 heur en
référence donc on peut garder les 35
heur en référence à condition de faire
que les les heures travaillé en plus
soit payé en heures supplémentair avec
une prime substantielle parce que là de
25 % par exemple là vous êtes dans la
justice là vous êtes dans quelque chose
qui respecte les droits des salariés oui
benah écoutez c'était pas la plus
mauvaise formule qu'il avait trouvé
Nicolas Sarkozy c'est en tout cas pas
sur ce plan que nous nous sommes
affrontés c'est sur bien d'autres sujets
oui notamment les déficits publics parce
que vous votre crédau depuis toujours
c'est il faut réduire les déficits
publics or là aussi tous les candidats
tous y compris alin Jupé de la droite
disent tant pis pour les 3 % puisqu'il
va falloir baisser les charges baisser
les impôts réinvestir est-ce qu'ils font
tous une erreur bon en tout cas euh je
ne crois pas du tout qu'on puisse être
dinvolte à l'égard des déficits et de la
dette le l'idée dans laquelle on
s'enferme qui est que après tout on va
envoyer valser les 3 % par-dessus les
moulins euh comme on comme on le comme
on le faisait autrefois dans une
expression populaire euh ça ne me paraît
pas crédible comment voulez-vous que les
autres pays européens qui ont fait des
efforts considérables acceptent cela en
revanche euh s'il faut trouver une
solution de
relance cette solution de relance pour
éviter les inconvénients qu'on voit
venir comme le mur euh face à la voiture
euh cette solution de relance ne peut
être qu'européenne et c'est notamment la
responsabilité de la banque centrale
européenne que de se préoccuper de la
relance nécessaire de l'économie
française elle le fait en partie
monsieur dragy vient de faire euh des
interventions qui vont tout à fait dans
ce sens-là je note au passage que c'est
quand même un dirigeant conscient des
problèmes qui se posent hein euh et qui
va dans ce sens-là euh la responsabilité
de la banque centrale européenne devrait
pour moi être enrichi par une référence
à l'obligation de chercher le plein
emploi c'est le cas de la Banque
centrale américaine oui et ce n'est pas
le cas et c'est pas le cas de la Banque
centrale européenne et nous devrions
nous nous devrions nous focaliser nous
devrions concentrer nos efforts tous les
dirigeants européens qui franchement
aujourd'hui n'apparaissent pas à la
hauteur il y a eu un sommet hier
Bratislava qui est
à parce que on n'en parle pas ils n'ont
rien dit et mattho Renzi a eu le courage
de dire rien pour la crise rien pour les
difficultés que nous traversons et il a
refusé de participer à la conférence de
presse on on a besoin de dirigeants
européens qui oblige à poser les
problèmes qui se posent au peuple une
dernière question c'est tout autre chose
qui se pose comme question là ici en
France Alain vidalis le secrétaire
d'État au transport annonce ce matin une
augmentation des tarifs d'autoroute de
03 à 04 % entre 2018 et 2020 pour
améliorer le réseau autoroutier vous
vous êtes très critique déjà sur la
privatisation des autoroutes c'est la
goutte d'eau toute cette opération de
privatisation comme elle est menée
depuis le début est un scandale
démocratique on a privatisé en créant
des sources de bénéfices considérables
pour les entreprises privées qui ont
repris les autoroutes on ne cesse
d'allonger la durée de ces concessions
donc ça veut dire quoi en prétendant que
ça va arranger les
choses non c'est impossible me suis
exprimé dès le premier jour en disant ce
qui est signé signé les contrats sont
tellement ficelés qu'on y arrivera pas
un faut demander des comptes aux gens
qui ont fait ça mais de il faut avoir en
tête que il faut rendre publi les
conditions de cette affaire il y a un
citoyen lanceur d'alerte comme on dit
qui a demandé le document du contrat on
a refusé de lui donner les tribunaux lui
donnent raison le ministère de
l'Économie refuse de mettre de mettre à
disposition des citoyens le contrat qui
a été signé avec les sociciété il faut
jouer la transparence oh c'est plus que
ça ouis écoutez-moi bien il faut séparer
le pouvoir politique des intérêts
économiques il faut qu'il y ait un un un
mur de verre qui qui
s'inst sinstalle je ne vise personne qui
s'instaure et qui s'installe ou je vise
tout le monde puisque c'est des
gouvernements successif le le comment
dirais-je le la trop grande proximité
entre les intérêts privés et l'État sont
un affaiblissement pour le pays comme le
montre la décision désastreuse prise sur
les autoroutes et on va encore augmenter
les tarifs alors puisque vous parlez
d'intérêt de la France on va se demander
si la France a un train de retard à
propos d'Alstom et de la politique
industrielle de la France est-ce que sur
Alstom le gouvernement aurait pu réagir
plutôt ben en tout cas le gouvernement a
menti aux gens au salariés talstom mais
plus gravement pourquoi il a menti
pourquoi vous dit mais parce qu'il a dit
qu'on fermerait jamais qu' aurait
pas pas un emploi serait mise en cause
et cetera et donc pour moi en tout cas
le le les décisions qui ont été pris
sous cette espèce de pression des
marchés depuis des années et qui font
que la France a été dépouillée de ces
instruments de ces outils industriels
les plus importants et si vous prenez
secteur après secteur alors vous voyez
que tout d'un coup ces logiques là qui
interviennent sont des logiques qui
privent la France de la capacité à agir
de la capacité à avoir une industrie à
avoir des centres de décision chez nous
tout cela c'est la même logique qui
depuis des années est au travail et
chaque fois c'est le même scénario ne
vous inquiétez pas il se passera rien
mais alors qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
est-ce qu'il faut obliger par exemple
les régions à acheté les TER chez Alstom
ou est-ce qu'il faut nationaliser Alstom
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire euh d'abord
il aurait fallu faire un géant européen
au lieu de donner aux Américains le la
prééminence qu'on leur acc
aujourd'hui si on peut pousser et
inciter les régions à acheter les trains
Alstom fabriqués en France en tout cas
je n'y verrai que des avantages je suis
favorable à l'idée qu'on favorise le
tissu économique et l'emploi et le tissu
industriel local au lieu de se trouver
dans une situation où nous nous
appauvrissons constamment François
Baayou on va parler de vous être au
centre c'est prendre le Paris parfois
d'être nulle part vous savez quand on
est au centre de quelque chose on est à
Carrefour aussi on peut aussi une mais
ça Rena d directeurenez la deuxè formule
Plô que la Rena directeur de la
rédaction de Marian est avec nous ce
midi bonjour bonjour Francis bonjour
franç bonjour bonjour Rena j'attendais
un peu voilà que la musique disparaisse
pour dire bonjour et qu'on vous et qu'on
vous entendre pour l'instant en tout cas
vous êtes en réserve le Centre en France
a du mal à se faire une place depuis
2002 votre première présidentielle c'est
vous qui l'incarnez mais il y en a eu
d'autres avant
vous pour le centrisme l'alternative est
très simple ou bien c'est lui qui
gouvernent avec ses idées ou bien c'est
d'autres qui gouvernent avec les idées
des centristes donc les centristes sont
toujours
[Musique]
heureux je suis Jean Le canuet je ne
suis pas un héros de légende mais un
homme parmi les hommes partageant vos
préoccupations et vos aspirations
Monsieur Jean Le canuet est en 3e
position avec 16 % des suffrages et
c'est un vrai coup de théâtre mettre en
ballottage de général de Gaulle le
centre de devient alors une force
politique
majeure il fallait que le centre droit
et le centre gauche en France devienne
une seule famille et c'est ce travail
qui a rendu possible en fait mon
élection de 74 créé en février 78 l'UDF
a vocation à soutenir l'action de giscar
François baayerou rentre dans le rang il
rejoint giscar et devient secrétaire
général de l'UDF un mouvement qui est en
train de grandir bien qu'il a choisi
contre Chirac les centristes ne sont pas
oubliés au moment de la composition du
gouvernement Jupé
oui il faut un trisè homme je suis
candidat à la présidence de la
République François baayrou ne réalise
pas son rêve d'être numéro 2 mais il est
le trè homme plus rien ne peut se passer
sans lui en créant le MoDem qui absorbe
aujourd'hui l'UDF François Baayou tourne
une longue page d'histoire après 2002 et
2007 François Baayou il retourne 10
points de moins qu'en 2007 des ambitions
en volé c'est un peu la gueule de bois
vous êtes prêt à un rapprochement du
MoDem avec l'UMP version Alain Jupé nous
sommes pas seulement amis mais j'ai pour
lui de l'estime et du respect je crois
que nous avons besoin plus que jamais de
nous rassembler je me sens en pleine
harmonie avec
lui François Baayou vous êtes l'héritier
de qui de Jean Le Canu ou de Valérie
giscardesttin ma famille politique c'est
le centre d'inspiration spiritualiste
comme le Canu disait d'autres disent
démocrates chrétiens mais ça s'arrête
pas au christianisme et et de la laïcité
voilà ce sont ces deux familles là j'ai
noté que jean-lué ça vous va bien ben
j'ai été son ami et son proche j'ai été
le secrétaire général de giscar pendant
5 ans et j'en ai été très heureux c'est
honnêtement si on devait faire le
classement des responsables politiques
des hommes politiques sur les 20 25 30
dernières années giscar était le
plus capable
intelligent il voyait les choses et il
avait une prestance intellectuelle on va
parler d'aujourd'hui voilà parlons parl
parlons d'aujourd'hui François Baou
c'est C tempsci vous répétez vous aimez
répéter vous n êtes jamais senti aussi
bien aussi en phase avec vous-même aussi
aussi libre pas mal en tout cas est-ce
que c'est parce que on l'a vu dans le
sujet à l'instant vous avez déjà été
candidat tro fois FO la présidentielle
et est-ce que c'est parce que cette
fois-ci vous avez décidé de passer votre
tour que vous vous sentez si bien non je
me sens très bien parce que c'est assez
rare en politique qu'on puisse faire
preuve
d'abnégation ça se produit presque
jamais qu'un responsable politique ayant
un socle de de soutien et même
d'intention de vote dans de popularité
de popularité ou de soutien d'intention
de vote disent écoutez je suis prêt à
aider quelqu d'autre donc vous
sououttiez l' Jup par abnégationi je
soutiens la Jupé parce que je pense que
c'est le mieux placé de ceux des
responsablebl politiques qui peuvent
être élus avec les deux points
nécessaires du programme auquel je crois
c'est-à-dire rassembler les Français au
lieu de les diviser leur parler comme
comme comme si on veut en faire ou en
voulant en faire une unité alors que
d'autres veulent les faire exploser et
deuxièmement porter un certain nombre de
réformes on peut av des débats sur les
réformes mais résoudre des questions
lancinantes qui se posent au pays depuis
longtemps cette volonté là est le
deuxème point du programme alors
François l'appellation officielle de
cette compétition des primaires ce sont
les primaires de la droite et du centre
alors la droite on la voit bien dans ces
primaires beaucoup même mais où est le
centre on cherche des espérments C c'est
l'appellation que les républicains ont
donné à cette compétition qui est une
compétition interne cela a dit si des
militants des citoyens des sympathisants
du centre veulent se servir de cette
élection ou choisisse d'intervenir dans
cette élection pour favoriser le choix
de quelqu'un qui peut faire la Réunion
l'entente l'union entre une partie de la
droite et le centre je trouve que ça
vaut la peine vous appelez donc
clairement vos électeurs vos
sympathisants du MoDem à aller voter
pour pour Alain Jup oui tous ceux qui le
veulent je les y encourage mais
vous-même à titre personnel vous avez
dit récemment que vous vous ne voteriez
pas vous à titre personnel lors de pas
récemment j'ai dit ça depuis la première
minute pour une raison extrêmement
simple si quelqu'un qui est un
responsable
politique avec tout ce que cela emporte
de vous voyez bien de
de d'éco dans le pays participe à une
compétition de cet ordre forcément
l'engagement implicite serait d'en
respecter le résultat et depuis le début
je dis qu'il il y a un résultat qui peut
réunir et un résultat qui diviserait et
je ne veux pas du résultat qui div c'est
Nicolas Sarkozi alors justement Nicolas
Sarkozi on se souvient en 2012 François
Baayou vous avez largement contribué à
sa défaite puisque vous aviez appelé à
voter pour François Hollande nombre de
militants de droite et de militants du
parti les républicains s'en souviennent
plutôt amèrement est-ce que vous êtes
certain que votre
soutien fervant en tout cas avec
abnégation Alain Jupé c'est vraiment une
aide que vous apportez àin Jupé auprès
de cet électorat de droite dé je peux
vous poser une question vous qui êtes
vous qui êtes un expert de la politique
absolument averti euh si je n'exprimais
pas ce soutien qui l'exprimerait et vous
vous pensez donc vous ne pensez pas que
vous avez entendu ma question oui mais
c'est vous qui répondez question c'est
je suis oui mais enfin c'est bien qu'on
ait un dialogue après tout
voilà Nicolas Sarkozy a très à de très
nombreuses repris ces derniers mois fait
siffler votre nom dans les meting qu'il
fait c'est pas grave et après tout c'est
un chacun a les jeux qu'il veut mais
vous voyez bien de quoi il
s'agit la structure d'opinion qui peut
emporter la victoire d'Alain jupet on la
connaît bien tous les sondages la
donneent c'est le centre au sens large
du terme centre droit centre et centre
gauche qui lui apporte à 70 % son
soutien je suis devant cet électorat là
je crois garant de
l'authenticité du soutien et de
l'authenticité de
l'indépendance que nous garderons est-ce
qu'il ne risque pas d'y avoir un peu un
embouteillage prochainement sur ce
créneau que vous venez de définir le
centre le centre droit et le centre
gauche avec l'apparition d'un nouveau
rival d'un nouveau concurrent sur lequel
vous tapez allagrement qui est Emmanuel
Macron je ne tape pas j'indiique les
choses quelle est quelle est sa nature
son poids politique aujourd'hui Emmanuel
Macron d'après vous moi je je ne crois
pas que que ce soit un poids déterminant
et qui durera parce que je ne vois pas
son projet ou en tout cas ce que je voix
du projet est extrêmement clair il a été
l'inspirateur de la politique économique
suivie par François Hollande et le
décideur les deux dernières années
principales de cette politique
économique et cette politique économique
est une catastrophe et elle est marquée
en particulier par ce que j'ai dénoncé
depuis le début de l'émission
c'est-à-dire l'idée que le monde du
travail on essayit perpétuellement de
réduire le salaire réel qu'il reçoit et
ça c'est signé Emmanuel Macron vous dit
entreut il est il est pas tout seul
évidemment le président de la République
a dû dire oui mais c'est lui
l'inspirateur le plus important puisque
c'est lui qui était au commande dans les
SAG et même dans les intentions de vote
François Baayou aujourd'hui Emmanuel
Macron est très populaire davantage que
franç Hollande et même devant vous dans
les intentions de vot franchement si
vous n'avez jamais rencontré dans la vie
des sondages qui à un moment de don dans
une campagne d'opinion donne des
résultats qui seront pas les résultats
au bout du compte c'est ce serait que
vous manqueriez d'expérience politique
et Monsieur déi j'ai pas l'impression
que ce soit le cas celle que justement
ces fameux sondages d'intention de vote
place en tête du premier tour quasi
systématiquement c'est Marine Le Pen
est-ce que vous vous écartez totalement
la possibilité que Marine Le Pen puisse
l'emporter au second tour au mois de mai
prochain je n'écarte jamais aucune
possibilité je me bats
contre comprenez le le l'enjeu le plus
important de cette élection c'est qu'en
effet les Français trouvent un espoir
parmi les candidats un espoir de
politique différente or on nous menace
d'avoir les deux mêmes candidats les
deux mêmes personnalités qui ont exercé
le mandat sur les 10 dernières années
alors ça fait évidemment le jeu de
Marine Le Pen si vous n'avez pas une
autre proposition politique alors les
Français euh d'une certaine manière
désespérée par cette
réédition
euh
attristante et bien ils peuvent se
donner à n'importe quel choix je
garantis que il faut proposer une autre
vision et je m'efforcerai de le faire
mais àin Jupé lui il peut faire naître
une proposition politique plus
rassembleuse profitons-en et c'est
pourquoi je lui apporte en effet euh mon
soutien amical s'il gagne la primaire
merci Renaud merci sur le plateau de
dimanche en politique on en parle et
vous disiez ça fait partie des thèmes de
la primaire notamment de l'immigration
par exemple les migrants le démenement
de calis d'abord 12000 migrants à
reloger 9000 nouvelles places à trouver
est-ce qu'il y avait une autre solution
oui le gouvernement est en train de
suivre une pratique qui est la
pratique classique
hélas des gouvernants ou de l'État en
France il décide tout seul
et il impose notamment aux collectivités
locales le le l'obligation de faire y
compris contre leur gré ce que lui
décide je pense que c'est la plus
mauvaise des Prati alors cétait quoi la
solution la solution c'était simple
c'était d'ouvrir un dialogue avec les
collectivités locales en disant voilà
écoutez on
a un certain nombre de personnes à qui
il faut que nous proposions autre chose
que la solution indigne épouvantable
qu'il y a à
Calais prenons les chiffres c'est 12000
personnes 12000 personnes c'est 120 par
département français vous croyez pas que
si vous ouvrez le dialogue avec les
maires et les présidents
d'intercommunalité pour un département
moyen français ils peuvent trouver la
solution pour
120 à à recevoir un centre de migrant
euh pas mais vous voyez bien vous êtes
dans toujours dans la logique du
gouvernement ça veut dire que vous ne
m'écoutez pas je ne suis pas pour des
centres où l'on concentre cette misère
je suis au contraire pour qu'on trouve
des localisations euh plus petites
décidé avec les par exemple ou dans le
département des pirénéses atlantiqu vous
trouvez que ça pour faire nous le
faisons et ça pourrait se faire à
condition qu'on laisse les élus
locaux empêcher précisément des
concentrations qui seraient pas viables
parce que plus vous concentrez la misère
plus vous avez des accidents et donc le
le le rôle qu'on devrait euh souhaiter
euh que les élus locaux jouent dans ce
drame- làà est un rôle facile possible
et que le gouvernement ses vertus comme
tous les pouvoirs successifs que le
gouvernement ses vertus a évité save
vous savez que ça fait les les les
chougras de la primère à droite Eric
cioti par exemple porte parole de
Nicolas Sarkozi dit c'est un vrai danger
pour la France de voir proliférer une
multitude de petits calés il il y va
trop fort en un mot mais je je pense que
cette idée de concentration même de
concentration répartie sur le territoire
est une très mauvaise idée et donc je je
plaide pour qu'avec les collectivités
locales il y a un dialogue de gens
responsables en disant il faut faire
quelque chose
comment so que ce soit inséré dans la
population et et donc accepter je
voudrais qu'on termine par l'instantané
de la semaine qu'on demande maintenant à
nos invités et vous nous avez envoyé de
de instantané finalement qui se
rejoignent ce sont les joueurs de de
poau en rugby top 14 ils ont écrasé le
Stade Français hier je donne le
scoreandême PE abattu Paris 23 c'est
quand même pas mal et puis un/art dans
la nuit alors expliquez-nous alors le le
à gauche c'est la sortie des joueurs
j'aime bien ce moment de fraternisation
quand les gladiateurs se sont beaucoup
affrontés et que au fond c'est la paix
qui r ils ont le sentiment d'avoir bien
fait leur travail je signale au passage
qu'il y a au centre au centre le le
meilleur joueur du monde à qui s'appelle
Kas SMI en tout cas un des meilleurs
joueurs du monde black et que vous voyez
là et à côté ce qui m'a frappé c'est je
sortais et vous m'aviez demandé une
photo et j'ai trouvé que la lumière de
ce de de cette sortie du stade alors que
tout le monde est en train de faire la
fête de l'autre côté avec ce ciel bleu
nuit et ces lumières oranges avaient un
air de fête foraine en plus il y avait
des odeurs de mergz et et et donc
j'étais d'une certaine manière ça m'a
mis victoire plus cette ambiance ser
vous a fait plaisir cé un bon samedi
soir la joie au cœur un bon samedi soir
comme vous en passez certainement
souvent merci François bairou d'avoir
accepté notre invitation